Warner Brothers dropped the first teaser trailer
for director Todd Phillips' Joker movie on
Wednesday, April 3rd, and the internet went
nuts as fans sparked a fiery debate over which
actor might be the better Joker: The Dark
Knight's Heath Ledger or the brand-new Clown
Prince of Crime, Joaquin Phoenix.
When it comes to The Joker, everyone has their
favorite version.
Some prefer Cesar Romero's portrayal of the
character on the 1960s Batman television series.
"And I can start planning the craftiest caper
of my career!"
Others think the 1980s brought the best-ever
interpretation of Mr. J by Jack Nicholson,
who played the Joker in Tim Burton's Batman
film.
"Do I look like I'm joking?"
A fair few out there are a little more radical,
preferring Jared Leto's silver-toothed, tattooed
take on the Joker in Suicide Squad.
"Bring the car around.
We're going for a drive."
And some people think the live-action versions
of the infamous character pale in comparison
to Mark Hamill's voiceover work.
"Hahahaha, let the good times roll."
But it's the late Heath Ledger who probably
captivates audiences the most.
"Why so serious?"
To this day, many fans still believe no one
can even come close to his stunning turn as
the Joker in Christopher Nolan's The Dark
Knight.
However, now there's a new Joker in town:
Joaquin Phoenix's Arthur Fleck, the aspiring
comedian who experiences a psychotic break
and becomes the Joker.
Unsurprisingly, social media and numerous
entertainment sites have been weighing in
on which actor may end up reigning the best
Joker.
Shortly after watching the footage of director
Todd Phillips' Joker, one fan took to Twitter
to say that Phoenix will be "the best Joker
we've ever seen."
Another fan wrote that Phoenix is "coming
for Heath Ledger's crown as the best Joker."
One Twitter user was so blown away by seeing
Phoenix in character that they placed an early
bet on the outcome of the film:
"Calling it now, Joaquin Phoenix is going
to be the best live action Joker."
Many fans were quick to bring up Ledger's
performance for direct comparison, with one
Twitter user writing:
"I have a great feeling that Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker is gonna better than Heath Ledger's"
Jemele Hill, a staff writer for The Atlantic,
feels like Phoenix might end up turning in
a better performance:
"I didn't think it was possible for anyone
to play the Joker better than Heath Ledger.
But Joaquin Phoenix looks like he's got a
shot."
Tia Fabi of Geek Vibes Nation wrote an opinion
piece about why Phoenix will probably go down
as one of the best Jokers in history, writing
in part:
Meanwhile, one fan was evidently prepared
to turn the online debate into a real-life
battle:
"Heath Ledger will never be replaced as the
best Joker.
Fight me."
Writer George M. Johnson wrote that people
should, quote, "let the Joker rest with the
best that did it."
That's clearly a reference to Ledger, who
passed away in 2008 at the age of 28.
Advocate April Reign later responded to Johnson's
tweet, writing:
"This is my thought as well.
Why anyone would even ATTEMPT this after Heath
is beyond me."
Clearly passionate about all things Joker,
professional Fortnite player Nate Hill tweeted:
"Heath Ledger's Joker was so good the character
should be retired...
I will compare every Joker to Heath and they
always will fall short."
The debate was just as hardcore over Instagram.
One individual wrote that Ledger is the best
Joker, and that, quote,
Another argued:
Some fans simply refused to choose a favorite
Joker and instead argued that comparisons
simply can't be made, as the actors appear
to be playing different iterations of the
classic character.
"Joaquin is portraying the early developments
of the Joker character…
Heath Ledger is the developed character in
the years following.
It'd be silly to compare the two."
Another fan basically asked the Internet to
stop being the Internet:
"Can we stop comparing, 'Who did this character
best?'
Please?
Ugh, online fandom is just taking the fun
out of everything I swear."
One Twitter user actually made a good point:
"Heath Ledger and Joaquin Phoenix were friends.
So, how about we stop with the extreme comparisons
of their Joker performances...
It's disrespectful and tasteless."
It goes without saying that these are just
a few selections out of the thousands of responses
fans posted after seeing the Joker teaser,
and opinions are bound to change as the film
nears its release date, and after we all finally
get to watch the thing.
Whether you're a fan of Phoenix, a longtime
Ledger-lover, or someone who still doesn't
want to pick sides, try to keep an open mind
about Joker… and try not to get into any
social media fights.
Joker will tumble into theaters on October
4th, 2019.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about DCEU movies
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.